here they are James Ransone anti-west
hi guys can see it welcome how's it
going welcome back what's going on of
course new movie in a valley of violence
it's a great name
thank you ten theaters by the way in on
demand on Friday yes on Friday yeah yeah
I mean I think the title is sort of a
play on words a little bit in the sense
that they are actually in a town that is
caught that is known as the valley
violence but I think it also kind of
speaks to the movie is sort of about
violence and how it affects people so
hopefully there's a little bit of
pretentious angle was the movie in the
in the car with some people and the
company of men I'm thinking about the
difference I thought had violence in the
title because that question is how you
spent your evening did you design the
like tighter because I saw the movie
last night it was it's so good because
it's a Western and it kind of I liked it
because it takes place over like two
days yeah like it's not this sort of
long epic thing but it gets very violent
very quickly which is which is nice yeah
were you asking you mean the title it's
like went through time yeah actual like
graphics of the title we see the guy in
his dog and the thing goes up that was
Neal right yeah a great artist named
Neal Jonas who has worked with a lot the
opening titles of this film are very
like spaghetti western style so they
have a kind of sergio leone type vibe to
them but he did a really amazing job and
i feel like a lot of people when you see
the movie there's an opening scene and
then there's this title sequence that's
like very bold and you're kind of either
in or you're out after that right either
see that and be like [ __ ] this movie or
you'll be like oh I'm down for whatever
this movie's gonna do which is kind of
what you want right that's the hope like
prime people to go alright this is the
right mindset to be yeah yeah that's
what's cool when like you allow like an
artist to create the vision as opposed
to a corporation yeah I mean yes like if
that went it was like a huge studio
maybe they'd be like absolutely [ __ ]
not not nice titles you know what I mean
yeah yeah - producer seem to love to
chime and do that yeah yeah all of our
bosses right
when did you guys find out that not only
with James being it but also like first
of all that you'd be playing John
Travolta's son well Ty and I have been
friends for a while when we were looking
for something to do and he I had worked
with Ethan on a couple of different
things aside from sinister and we had
known each other for a while he's like
hey I think I'm gonna make this Western
with Ethan I was like oh cool and then
he wrote it so fast he's like here I
wrote this part for you and then John
Travolta's sort of kr8
finding out that he was gonna do it sort
of came after me I was like holy [ __ ]
okay you didn't know when you first okay
no no well I mean because we had been
friends for a while he's like hey I
wrote this thing for you so I knew that
I was gonna do the movie I think before
anybody else did
yeah you write like so was Ethan Hawke
kind of down to do it yes or and well
what happened was I had an idea of what
this movie was and I was interested in
Ethan maybe being in it so I went to I
came in New York and met with Ethan and
he was doing Macbeth at Lincoln Center
and I kind of pitched him the idea for
the movie and he dug it and I was like
well when do you finish Macbeth and he
said I'll be done in about three weeks
and I said okay when you wrap I'm gonna
send you the script and if you don't
like it then we never have to talk about
it again but if you do like it let's
make it and he was like cool whatever I
went back to doing Macbeth
I went home frantically wrote a script
you had no script at all no I just had
the idea how long did it take you to
write it three weeks
Jesus respectful of his art like wow man
this guy won't interrupt my being
Macbeth well well and with the script
and you're just like I have [ __ ]
nothing to send you yes correct
he didn't say send it tonight I have
time oh you know I just want to polish
it up before you you know I want to make
sure it's just right because you were
like if he says he's not interested I'm
not gonna bother writing yeah that was
yeah cuz if you didn't want to do I
didn't know how I would get the movie
made because a Western is sort of an
esoteric band to get made nowadays yeah
but I was like well if Ethan wants to do
it then there's a life for this movie
and so he wanted to do it and after that
the producer Jason Blum was like hey
what about John Travolta and I was like
ah he was like because he read the
script and I was like well let's go have
dinner with John Travolta and see what
that's like and it was weird cuz we you
know that's what surreal experience in
his own right but we went to dinner with
John Travolta and he was awesome like he
was so great and
like so down-to-earth and totally
understood the script it got all the
humor because even though the movies
very violent there's a lot of sort of
like really like dark comedy in the
movie yeah and he got all of it and just
he just totally understood them it was
really amazing to sit down with John
Travolta and have him say all these
things about the script they're like
well that was like what was in my head
when I wrote it and he was just super
enthusiastic to do it so all of a sudden
it was this Ethan Hawke John Travolta
James ransom and how many how many
rewrites for there I mean in three weeks
there's not a whole lot of time to go
over things and redo them and go over
and read them well that's kind of all I
did for three weeks okay that's I
typically do that like I I wanted him to
like that deadline was helpful for me
because it forced me to be like if I
don't like myself hatred is like if I
don't get it done three weeks I'd be
failing just I'd be looking like an ass
so I have to get this done yeah it's a
Ty's credit to writing is the biggest
nightmare in the entire world I've I
have always used the metaphor it's like
trying to masturbate on the observation
deck of the Empire State Building it's
just easy and it's fun it's impressive
to watch something to be like I'm in a
lot I'm gonna sequester myself in my own
home in like where I live because a lot
of writers I know who get are like you
know know that they're gonna dive in
they'll they'll go to a cabin where
there's no internet service you know a
lot of people really do that so for him
to be like I'm gonna write this thing
I'm gonna write it in this amount of
time is pretty unusual
for Hollywood yeah it's hard to do to to
make yourself right because for me when
I write it has to come at a weird time
or it has to hit me I can't just sit
down and go okay I got three weeks to do
it do it I'm awful under this but when
it does hit you like that you're able to
do I mean you're a really productive
person but so are you able to then when
that hits you just do it all cuz I it's
very hard for me to sustain them I know
I have I have moments from fighting it
to computers the worst being online is
so hard so I literally will be creative
in between [ __ ] like you know
jerk-off Jags like that's what it is
it's a matter of okay I have this hour I
feel creative and I'm not doing anything
dirty take advantage of I was like empty
mind right so it's like gotta come
through from some other thing Laurie
it's your mind just becomes this clear
thing for something to pour out of yeah
when there's nothing filthy going into
it and all the sudden the doors
then the exit is apparent and thinking
otherwise all the windows are open she
just junk is flying in right do you have
a wife or a girlfriend no I'm single I'm
not asking you no okay cuz there's about
to say that's you would have to explain
like hey I'm not gonna see you for a
while yeah it really makes things weird
I mean in the past I've had that and
it's a it's a strain for sure yeah by
the way I've been saying your name we're
all not betting ranch on ransom
I don't know me my brother talked about
this we may have been misprint come from
a long line of white-trash bricklayers
so now they've been here since like the
17th century nobody figure out how to
buy property so my family was the people
that came over and there were like two
guys a mom was like well this is mine
and my family went I guess I work for
you now all right
how do you say it Ransome okay that's
all say it what did you go to South
Africa for I read that you went to South
Africa um I went to South Africa well it
wasn't just South Africa was name maybe
a South Africa and Mozambique and I was
there for almost a year for a television
show in 2008 called Generation Kill that
was yeah that was made by David Simon
and Evan Wright and Ed Burns about a
book that was originally a I think like
a three or four part a story for Rolling
Stone about the invasion of Iraq like
the initial of a invasion in 2003 so we
were it was like a dramatization of a
true story I remember that it was great
we interviewed you for it and yeah what
I kept saying moose - yeah I remember
being I'm kind of fascinated by the
whole process of getting this thing made
so so - right cuz like you look at it
and like we've known you for a while and
it's like and then you end up getting to
pull off a Western with these two guys
to do so is it that you build up enough
credibility that like you
Ethan Hawke will sit down with you and
then once you get him to sit down with
you then you guys name attached then you
can shop it around then somebody will
buy that like how does it how does the
process work at all that is sort of how
it works but in in the case of this
movie well one thing that's helpful what
I sort of learn is if you write a
Western like dudes want to be in
westerns so it was easier to cast then
like I'd made horror movies before this
which are harder to cast because like
everyone thinks the HAR movie might be
terrible so like
I don't mind being in a good horror
movie but nobody wants to be in a bad
horror movie right a Western people are
more like well this could be cool this
is sort of the dream is to get to make a
Western so especially for like male
actors it was it was relatively easy but
Ethan had done two movies the purge and
sinister of the producer named Jason
Blum and I had met him and I was like
well if Ethan wants to do the movie
would you do it and he has a unique
ability to get movies made pretty
quickly as long as they're inexpensive
so as soon as Ethan wanted to do it I
just sort of went back to Jason was like
look it doesn't cost very much money and
he was like alright let's do it you know
and then was Travolta got attached
especially it went very quickly
yeah well but he did yet bigger meaning
financially he's he's like oh he's
obviously in a different price range
private and most guys just just the
writer and the trailers do they kind of
forego a lot of that for a lower budget
movie he was very cool with us I think
because he was really into this movie
and that was like that dinner I had with
him he really wanted to do it and I
think you know you just sit down you
talk to him you go like look here's the
reality of what we can do and I don't
want to ask you to do something you
don't want to do but here's the reality
so could you bend the rules for us a
little bit and he's really he was great
because the trailer summertime that Will
Smith's trailer it's like at the back of
the gym things the big gym yeah it's
like a whole thing especially if you're
a city and you got to shut down streets
I mean that's a tremendous amount of
money yeah but let me tell you the man
it's not the 90s anymore like that's
it's I mean like you maybe have like a
couple of guys who can get away with
that still but I'd like to dispel the
illusion here and now that it's easy to
get anything made in Hollywood ever even
if you're yeah I mean that's the weird
thing and like we're entering this age
of transparency and really what it comes
down to is that like the most successful
directors even the ones that have been
making [ __ ] for a long time that have
made the studio's a lot of money are
constantly spinning like six or seven
plates and they're out there gonna go
with whatever whichever one goes first
whichever one that somebody is we'll
give you the money for that's the one
that they're gonna make do you know what
I mean and just that's across the board
and if you even do enough sort of like
digging on that like Scorsese is the
same one way you know what I mean it's
like he might have like three or four or
five scripts going and then it's like
whichever one is gonna get the money
first that's the one they're gonna shoot
yeah that Heyman said Travolta did have
a very nice trailer I know it's a weird
question to ask about the trailers but I
mean the amount of money that those
things cost
remember correctly he owns his he had
his own plane - he does he flew to set
did he yeah Wow pretty cool did you get
to go on the plane didn't I well I'd
love to still do that though but we did
a 707
yeah challenge Roy yes he had to right
he got rid of the bigger one and then
Qantas was the one who trained him and
they had the oh yes so like if you
actually fly with Travolta he's like one
of the best pilots to fly with because
Qantas he's a crazy amount of hours like
he's I mean he's a fascinating person to
talk to I mean that's mostly what we
would talk about is like flying because
I was like when did you get in this and
it was like when he was very young like
Welcome Back Kotter young is when he got
into flying yeah he's like a legitimate
like that can carry passengers pilot
yeah yeah I think that for a while he
was telling us that like once in a while
Qantas would call him and ask him to
like do like some PR trip you know for
like and he would be the pilot right can
you imagine getting on like this is your
captain speaking
it wouldn't be bad now but if it was
Vinnie Barbarino days not to be kind of
I want face off era yeah now confident -
with an actor flying me Bruce Dickinson
for my maiden flies like yeah you know
he's able to fly the the band and a lot
of people don't Jimmy Buffett can fly
his own playing there's a lot of those
guys but just I guess they want
something just totally distracting from
acting whatever it is how do you like at
what point when you're making the deal
are you like yeah but the point of this
movie is I'm the director and the writer
and the editor like I need all the
responsibilities put on me is that is
that a negotiation is that something
that you have to fight for because I
don't lie to trust to put everybody
right and the yeah that's true well
since I wrote it like that part has
already started and that they kind of
knew I wanted director so those two
things combined isn't that difficult
editing is abnormal I I'm an oddball
that likes to do that it's a little bit
of a thing but you know you just say
like this is important to me to do this
and yes it's not a huge thing but uh
yeah it is a trumpet that movie was a
pretty small me it was not a overly
expensive movie so you get a little if
this was like a hundred million dollar
movie yeah there's no way I'd be editing
yeah what was a tangerine like James
because tangerine was this movie that
made kind of a big splash yeah that was
shot entirely
I love that yeah absolutely nothing for
me there's something about just the way
that I was born naturally where I fell
out of the narrative - what was exciting
about that movie I had worked with Shaun
Baker before who actually met when my
dog got hit by car here in Chelsea it
was really weird
and he was there with his dog and my dog
was like about to die and then they were
holding me hostage for like 7,500 bucks
they were like well you can give us the
money or you know he's that's it and it
was and Shaun happened to be there it
was like 3:00 in the morning he was like
hey I I really liked you from the wire
and I was like thanks man and then we
started seeing each other around and so
he was like hey I'm gonna go do this
movie about porn in the valley called
starlit which was with dree Hemingway
that we all won a couple of Independent
Spirit Awards for and then when he was
like I'm gonna make tangerine week um I
was like sure and he was like I'm gonna
shoot it on iPhones and my whole thing
was like okay well I don't care what we
shoot it on mic you know the last thing
we worked on won a bunch of awards so
why would I think you know what I mean
like whatever you're using is not it's
not directors the artist right like yeah
the the the thing the interface in which
you cap the capture medium doesn't
really matter so when we filmed it it
was rough it was a rough because it's
like you know it's like a three-person
crew everybody's [ __ ] all over the
place we're shooting in non locked-off
locations so that donut time was still
open Wow right yeah and that's the witch
and the donut time recently just closed
but that corner is like you I mean there
was like meth heads and bombs like that
were interrupting the shots so they
could hustle money out of us so that
they you know cuz we'd be like cut and
you know so it was a it was a total it
was total chaos is that donut place
that's Santa Monica Boulevard and
Highland and and that's near Hollywood
Center studios is it yeah I think so oh
yeah I've driven by there quite a few
times a huge pain in the ass I mean it
wasn't it was just it's just when you
start to get like a rhythm going you
know when you're doing a scene and you
you have you know dialogue to do and
even if it's not scripted when when the
rhythm isn't interrupted you're like oh
that was a wasted tape right you know
what I mean Wow
interrupt you just for money for money
and then also like people come and be
like can I get a you know like an eclair
you know what I mean you're like okay
but it would cost you much to lock them
off yeah I mean it's weird though
because again back to my point about
like who controls the content its those
are the risks if you want to make
something really interesting like you
are always going to be subject to the
people that are paying for it and more
and more these days they think they know
what they're doing more than the artists
do and when they say there's Sean on
iPhones like is it literally just a guy
holding an iPhone or their iPhone rigs
with alcohol stuff on them yeah I mean
they sort of like just use the capture
medium in a way where they were like
okay well if we're gonna use this as a
camera don't we want to sort of like
experiment with the lenses and and there
were interesting things where they
there's Steadicam shots where you can
get a thing called a smoothie that's the
same technology as Steadicam that you
know basically suspends the phone in
space so there's not like a lot of you
know what I mean it's not shaking it and
then for like the boom shots it would be
the that taped on the end of like a
paint pole right and then Sean would
actually ride for the tracking shots
you'd ride on a bicycle holding it right
yeah and then so there's extra lenses on
it but then you also run the actual
footage through an app I think called
filmic Pro I think that's the one that's
called and that way you can like lock
color temperature and you know you can
lock the ISO the shutter and all that
stuff so it was really interesting
there's a lot of walking and kind of
back kind of frantic back-and-forth
dialogue it didn't look like an easy
film to shoot well I think again and and
this is also to Ty's credit in terms of
going like what you like editing I
always find that the that really good
filmmakers the ones that like are making
something interesting or you feel their
voice in them they also edit you know
what I mean right
yeah Sean edited that himself so you
know like that's that's a real beauty
and sort of why Sean Baker's movies are
really good I think cuz he started as an
editor so he knew how he was gonna cut
the whole thing together
I'm bad at it or I get married to stuff
you don't let anything go oh yeah well
if you wrote something it's hard to see
it
get cut realized wow that's just not
what I thought it was yeah it is true
even writing how long did the edit okay
cuz I was it didn't seem like like it
couldn't taken too long to shoot right
because it was all yeah I'm the one when
she said I think within 20 22 23 days
what a movie is really short like it
sounds like enough time but if you if
you say that number in front of like
people who make movies are like watts so
yeah you know you got three weeks to
write the script you got three weeks to
shoot it yeah a little R it's about I
mean we probably edited for two and half
months and then so it's not like this
thing where like you have to dedicate
two years of your life to this project
what you do but it's not as
compartmentalizes that so it has been
two years since I wrote I wrote it like
this we'd be coming up on either two or
it's actually been no cuz we shot it in
2014 so it's actually been three we're
coming up no we're coming up on three
years to when you were like I'm gonna go
to New York and pitch this to you yeah
so then even once you you you edit the
movie but then it's a small movie so the
sound and music I mean the music is
really great in this film and the
composer Jeff grace who's working me a
lot he did it all himself for like
nothing so that takes forever and you
can't really rush it along because
everyone's doing you favors so that
takes a long time there's a really
incredible dog in the film and you know
when you have to make all the dog bark
sounds and all the paw puts if that
stuff takes forever that's what I was
thinking it's like I was thinking about
you because obviously it's it's got an
independent feel to it and you as the
writer and know you're gonna be the
director and want to be the editor like
I feel like if I was writing a movie
that I was gonna do I would want to make
it as simple as possible and like you
watch the dog does so much stuff in that
I get to find a trained dog that can do
all this stuff yeah I mean as soon as I
sort of finished the script I had this
moment of like oh [ __ ] I wrote a movie
where I'm one of the main characters is
dog what do they tell you is a horrible
thing to do like pets and animal or
animals and kids kids are worse chimps
are very hard to work with as well
yeah they pull your face off yeah
they're the worst that was what the
animal trainer was saying he was like
they're literally the worst most scary
them that and bears bears are like
they're the most unpredictable chimps
and bears I did a pilot for MTV years
ago where I was
my co-host was a chimp not my proudest
moment know what you know what
I wouldn't be worried about this because
we found this out the other night which
was my sort of suspicion is that do you
know the most do you know the
highest-grossing adjusted for inflation
movie that Clint Eastwood has made as an
actor that the biggest box-office
success well because you said him I'm
gonna have to say either every which way
but loose running which way you can't
one and two Wow Wow
yep that was that was an orangutan got
Clyde yeah Oh
Doug Benson's podcast we learned that
and Doug just text me this what do you
say hello he's been listening oh yeah
you've done the that's right the in
anything you've done his are douglas
movies yeah we did the other night you
all you both did did you guys win Taiwan
I came in second I did it with Morgan
Spurlock and of course he won I did [ __ ]
I do twice I have no clue who won I know
I didn't win but I don't remember who
won we were you and I were on one
together yeah that's right with Morgan
no with Ron Bennington Oh with Ron Ronny
Ronny win it and Esther ku who was
terrible yeah actually knew none of it
yeah ron has a really good knowledge of
movies he does but it's amazing how you
panic you think you have a good
knowledge of movies then in front of an
audience I panic you do I'm comfortable
in for an audience but just not picking
out and [ __ ] obscure movie reference
isn't like I've never seen do forget
really obvious things yeah you would
know any other time of the day you're
Apocalypse I'm like some day so what do
you do then like when you're just
sitting there like okay my part of this
movies done it now the sound guy has it
like you have to move on with your life
or find ways to make money elsewhere
like what like what do you yeah you're
working making out what the next project
is mega movies a really traumatic thing
I feel like so it cuz it goes on for a
very long time and so the other sound
guys working on it but it's not like I'm
not involved in something like this and
something where the sound is very
particular the music very particular
like I'm a freak like that so I'm sort
of up in their business the whole time
so it's hard to move on I'll do an
episode of a TV show now I think I did a
show called wayward Pines I'd go and do
a couple episodes right and that sort of
like supplements the income yeah and you
know that's fun and you get a little
break for that and then you finish the
movie and then we premiered at South by
Southwest but we finished the movie
months before that so then you wait for
that and then you do that and then we've
been doing like a year of film festivals
to promote the movie and but that's a
year of the movie being done that it's
not out that you're traveling around
promoting like you know and then finally
here we are and it comes out for
but it's been you know it's a long time
so it's hard you can't go to another
movie because then you can't properly
focus yes totally unless you're the kind
of person who can like distance
themselves from but when you like write
direct edit pretty it's it's yeah it's
very much like it's a very personal
thing you don't miss an opportunity to
promote it or do something with it
because you're off doing something yeah
and like with like wayward Pines persons
I go there in six weeks I'm done
everything my whole bowl is done my
edits turned in they do whatever they
want with it see you guys later thing
and you don't you don't find yourself
attached to know that all you do that
job it's their show I'm just in help it
out well when Ethan Hawke does
Magnificent Seven are you like what the
[ __ ] I had the Ethan Hawke Western like
how did this know cuz he was so excited
about doing westerns that and he's like
really well-suited for it so I think
it's I mean I just like to see more
westerns in general so because I'm a
huge fan of this genre so no I think
it's great I mean hopefully it just
helps makes people that movie did very
well so hopefully it makes people
remember that westerns are cool and it
highlights and it's a very different
it's a very different movie yeah it's
very different yeah but uh but Noah the
more westerns the merrier I like certain
westerns like again like Sergio Leone
westerns yeah I love a lot of them I
don't tend to like those are amazing but
there's weird [ __ ] that I think falls
under the category of westerns that we
don't necessarily sort of like look at
you know like Salomon Louise's the
Western to you know right in those sort
of like most classic sense and anything
where you can hit the individual sort of
like on the road somewhere in America to
me is always like a Western and in some
ways like Mad Max is a Western do you
know what I mean like the original ones
yeah you know what I mean like the road
war it's like that that's just a
different type of Western there's no
he's have to be a showdown at the okay
Corral no it's about like one moral
person in like a completely [ __ ]
lawless society that is like left's is
sort of their own moral compass to
decide what's right or wrong you know
and it's like usually in the desert I
think that to me qualifies as a well
that's a good point the desert is such
an unforgiving shitty place yeah nobody
wants to be stuck in the desert
well that's why that was sort of wheat I
and I were talking about this in the
interview last week it was like why are
we seeing this resurgence of the Western
it's like well cuz that's sort of like
what it feels like right now a [ __ ]
completely [ __ ] up lawless society
just left we're just in this total chaos
and each person feels like they're on
some cowboy riding through some
hellscape you know yeah like I can see
that I get after
see that way of life happening like
that's that's where we're headed Oh a
hundred percent well I don't like the
Old West like when Joe on with John
Wayne recently I was in the gym
obviously and I'm working and I'm
watching and I'm watching this on the
treadmill and it's [ __ ] John Wayne
gets shot I forget which one it was but
he barely reacts I think that those are
the ones I don't really enjoy I think if
you're if you like the sort of spaghetti
westerns of surgical earnest type stuff
I think I think this movie you dig and I
think like I think people Travolta's
like really really great and really
really funny in the movie and I think
people are sort of surprised by that but
it's I think if you like that that's
sort of dark sense of humor and that
sort of black comedy from the spaghetti
westerns I think this movie is more
which makes it so different than
something like Magnificent Seven or
something like that yeah talk to some
more traditional thing this movie has
like kind of like a wacky edge to it
yeah the comedy does catch you off guard
because like you end up like listening
to these conversations that are
happening in the middle of this I quit
it's like all these sort of archetypes
that we're familiar with and it sets up
a story that's like not a surprising
plot you're like okay I kind of know
where this is going I know who these
types of people are and then when the
[ __ ] hits the fan all these characters
that you think are gonna react just like
they always do in movies start reacting
more like us they're like people in real
life yeah and so when the violence
happens in this movie everyone actually
turns out to be in way over their head
so they all want the vyas they all talk
[ __ ] I mean the whole movie starts
because you know James is talking [ __ ]
to Ethan and that's he's trying to start
a fight and then Ethan beats him in a
fight and that starts the whole problem
of the movie right but that's kind of
what the movie is is the guy that talks
the biggest [ __ ] that ends up getting
knocked out and then he can never let it
go and and everybody cuz he's kind of a
wiener throughout the whole movie yeah
thanks ok here's a good news James
you're gonna be able to have your role
in a Western but you're kind of a wiener
one trouble with this fiancee and like
you have one of the scenes it's just
like relationship problems like yes I
guess like you know anti 7 your script
it's always it's just so it's always
more fun to play the bad guy because
there's so much so much more that you
can do and then you know I think it was
like a couple of years ago he's like I
really want to write to your strengths
and I think that just comes from doing
the wire and now I'm like yeah it's a I
really I enjoy playing those villains
and it's great if somebody wants to pay
for it it's just I get
bored of it I get burnt out after a
while that's because it's boring you
know what I mean like at a certain point
of malaya alley yeah we're like playing
that type of character which is like an
insecure person like daddy issues it's
like okay like you know what I mean
yeah maybe because you're good at it but
it's not easy to pull off and you pull
it off really well
and that's so thank you thanks man but
again it's like you know it's it's I
think like with anybody it's like you
start to go like wait is this is my like
a one-hit wonder sort of right right I
mean yeah I always like William HMAC is
like one of the great actors of all time
and he's kind of always cast as that
like oh he just didn't make it
schmuck just missing yeah yeah and it's
so degree like Phil Hoffman a little bit
- he always looks like he just got done
masturbating you know yeah just didn't
quite work out but the first time I said
William H Mason it might have been his
first major thing was a house of games
that mammoth plays the guy that they
[ __ ] take advantage of in the bus
station whoever is just such a great
schmuck yeah I bet if you press the
money probably feel the exact yeah I
know I don't want to be the schmuck
every time no I'm sure he does and I'm
sure that that's why a lot of guys who
are like journeyman they like to go do
theater because they like to you know
it's like you start to get paid I think
again because we live in a we work in an
industry that has a zero imagination so
it's like okay well if this is gonna pay
for my livelihood I guess it's like what
I'm gonna do
yeah but then where do I sort of you
know expand creatively elsewhere I think
that that's why you'll see a lot of all
the actors that I really respect will
all do theater their off time you know
theater yeah went one yes I have started
to in the last couple of years but it's
usually got to be a very specific
material that I respond to because it's
a lot of work it's at work yeah I'm
reading this I probably should prepare
about it did you really stop a rape in
2006 yes how did you do it uh uh um
fisticuffs it's oh do you want to do on
the full story well yeah and that's a
pretty interesting thing I mean we've
never heard that story before so I it's
ridiculous I am like a ex-heroin addict
and at 2006 I was on a lot of heroin
and I was living in my apartment this
like shitbox on Allen Street and broom
and I was watching TV with my then
girlfriend at the time and I I was like
in just pajama bottom so it was like
April and it was raining a little bit
and I hear this scream for help
right right hear this commotion
downstairs and I I ran down and I was
literally at the landing of the stairs
there's like two double doors you know
or there's double doors in New York and
in the sort of hallway vestibule between
the doors was my I could see my upstairs
neighbor pinned down on the ground face
up and this guy was like trying to rape
her basically and so I ran back upstairs
just to the landing and I went inside it
told my girlfriend I was like listen
lock yourself in here call the police
like tell the cops to come right now
like on heroin right and so I run
downstairs and I open the door and she's
on the ground the guy has left and I
grab a metal pipe because it's an a
[ __ ] building in Chinatown so there's
just [ __ ] everywhere right so I got this
metal pipe when I run out the landing
and there's nobody on the street I
looked north and I look south and
there's this guy on Allen Street and
he's running south and I'm like oh this
is the [ __ ] right so I'm there
I'm like a hundred and fifteen pounds
soaking wet
like y'all you know in pajama bottoms
and I'm like hey [ __ ] like are
you trying to rape my neighbor and he
turns around and he Minds having like a
gun in his sweatshirt pocket and he goes
I'm the police and I'm like [ __ ] you and
I hit him with his metal bar right and
he fights me and he takes off running
and I go after him he bolts into some
apartment like a housing complex like
just I think like you know near Allen
and grand and he slams my arm in the
door yeah and I smash the glass with
this pipe cuz I'm trying to get a hold
of him and I slip because it's wet and
so I end up like sir aiding my entire
chest in broken glass
so I basically look like Iggy Pop right
Wow and the cops show up and they think
I'm the rapist because I'm like a junkie
like blood right and I'm like no no it's
the other guy and so what happened was
they picked him up I think a couple
hours later
and then I had to go like pick him out
of a lineup and then testify against him
in court I don't know what I don't know
what ended up happening but that's
that's the story so when when you hit
the pipe where'd you hit him like in the
shoulder oh no you know it wasn't like
I'm not I'm not some super skillet right
Steven Seagal no I mean I'm also like
you know like was a hundred and fifteen
pound junkie with a pipe actually gonna
do to you by the way how slow is he that
the guy on heroin coins yeah so that's
that's the story that's pretty ballsy to
chase him down with super bowl how did
you kick heroin that I went to rehab I
mean I had a pretty bad bottom I guess
yeah yeah it was bad and that was after
the wiris 2006 oh yeah so what people
don't understand is they were like
you're so good at playing a junkie and
it was like no I didn't actually start
doing heroin till after the wire like I
was a drunk when I was filming the wire
but then I was doing I got the way I got
to do it was I took a lot of
prescription pills so and that's and and
and I have like a real weird drugstore
Cowboys story where I would like steal
scripts from doctors forge them under
different names and promote of the city
and pick him up from Duane Reade's under
fake names and then I ended up feeling
like one of my friends with a jail for
that you went to Rikers I was like this
is gonna get to this is this is too
sketchy you know what's a [ __ ] it's
real sensible move is to go to heroin
because that's like a it's cheaper and
it's an easier thing to get a hold of so
that's you not to forge anything yeah
no bits and and then you know and then
you know cuz I've been I've been clean
for like ten years and it's weird when
you when I think about it now and I
think about how I got hooked on pills
and then looking at the pharmaceutical
industry I'm like no they're just drug
dealers that somehow legitimized it it's
like I wear a white coat it's like yeah
but this is still heroin how'd you do it
under fake name I'm amazed with no ID
and stuff they weren't asking for as
much idea it was probably like a
different time you know I mean it's like
this was I think before it really got
into sort of like the cultural zeitgeist
of like how and slike cuz I remember
cleaning up and a couple years after
that it was like all those Florida pain
clinics they were like okay this is
really unethical what's happening right
now they're still around those Florida
you know I mean I don't know man it's
I'd see so many people still strung out
on oxycontin though it's like its they
you know they just figured out a way to
hide
yeah if the rock seemed to get have a
very easy time getting vicodin on
ballers so yeah that's where I get my
life lessons from yeah I've never seen
it well it's great show terrific show
yeah well listen the movies great
in a valley of violence it's in theaters
and on demand this Friday and I would
recommend everybody see it and it's even
cooler that like it's actually a project
that a person and people did like it's
not this big kind of conglomerate thing
it's liked I went and wrote and directed
and edited and James was in it and Ethan
Hawke and John Travolta playing a weiner
play it like a weiner the character I
mean the character that's some of the
way it's also worth the dog's name is
jumpy and I would recommend anyone
Google jumpy cuz it's the there's
probably only one dog on planet Earth
they can do what jumpy can do and if you
checked it like I found jumpy by
googling talented dogs and he was the
first one that came up and I mean he can
skateboard when I say skateboard I don't
mean like kind of I mean he can go in a
halfpipe and go up and come back down I
could just go forward there's a trip
that he like he'll have five people
stand like four feet apart and pick
numbers between one and ten and no like
two six you know go jumpy go to six and
he'll go and put its paw on the foot of
the person who's at six Oh Mike yeah and
you know the when you make a movie with
the doggy then this can be really hard
you put a mark down just like you would
for an actor and you go jump you go to
your mark and it goes and puts his paws
on the marsh and stays there until you
say cut like it was the it's incredible
I've never experienced anything like it
and the dog is it's really like there's
a lot of really special YouTube he can
paint and sign his name he's amazed as
wild he's amazing and he's good in the
movie too it's a good yeah he's a good
movie does a transgender role he plays a
girl in the movie Oh a lot of new ground
very forward-thinking
yeah take that tangerine